hey youtubers its charlie happy
Halloween this week on arrow we learned
the secret identity of the canary as
well as two new big villains this season
including brother blood and Amazo Corp
we also learned that there is more than
one way to save a city
the second way involves some really
weird green serum don't take the serum
first let's talk about the most
important stuff and then I'll do my
review right off the bat high-five
yourself if you already guessed the
secret identity of the canary they
already kind of broke the news that it
was gonna be Sara Lance obviously
laurels sister after Comic Con it was
basically in the casting sheets so if
you have been looking for spoilers it
was pretty easy to find but the big
question is is what she's gonna be doing
this season they kind of introduced her
in opposition to Oliver but now it kind
of looks like they're gonna be teaming
up a lot there are some behind the
scenes images that show her in a police
uniform so it looks like that's going to
be what her day job is going to be on
the show you know the big thing about
her teaming up with Oliver this season
also includes comic book logic wherein
as the number of Heroes increases on a
show the number of villains increases
exponentially which leads me to brother
blood
so obviously I'm really excited that
they revealed the identity of brother
blood as Sebastian blood I think a lot
of people kind of expected that so it's
not a huge surprise but the mystery is
is what is he doing with that green goo
that he's injecting people with
obviously it's related to the maze Okur
but we still really don't know a lot
about what a maze oh Corp is actually
doing with that stuff that actually
leads me to the Big Bad this season
although they've only kind of teased it
on the show and in the promos the League
of Assassins is basically where the Big
Bad is coming from this season and
obviously there's a connection between
them and Sara Lance and also I'm
guessing between them and Amazo Corp and
this green serum the funny thing too is
that that mask that brother blood was
wearing is actually a bit of a cross
between save the Scarecrow's mask and
Bane's mask which is kind of funny
because that kinda leads us to the
Batman universe and if you remember in
Batman Begins they were injecting people
with the fear serum the Scarecrow was
and who was behind that well the League
of Assassins so on this show it's
probably the League of Assassins that
are also behind this green serum too we
just don't know what it does yet in
psychic territory we also got some nice
scenes with Roy and sin we don't know a
lot about sin yet I don't know why she's
working with Sarah hopefully they'll
kind of flesh that character out as the
season gets on because it's actually
pretty interesting if you're not a comic
book reader in the Marvel Universe not
the DC Universe where this show takes
place but in
Marvel Universe sin is actually the name
of the red skull's daughter obviously
it's not really connected to these DC
characters but it's just a funny
coincidence I also want to know which of
you out there are upgrading Roy and sin
from ship status to OTP status and who
else got really excited when they made
that flash teaser at the end of the
episode they kind of keep teasing it as
episodes go along it's all about this
STAR Labs particle accelerator so
clearly that's where Barry Allen is
going to get his Speed Force from we
just don't know how it's gonna happen
it's probably gonna be some sort of
accident I think the big questions after
this episode are or what brother Bloods
true intentions are what he's going to
be doing to take over the city or fix
the city as the quote-unquote says what
is in that green serum and what Amazo
corpse ties to it are but what did I
think of the episode overall it was my
favorite episode so far it drove the
most important plots forward in a really
big way we found out who the canary was
what she's gonna be doing this season
what her relation to Oliver is going to
be obviously she's going to be an ally
we learned who the middle bat is brother
blood we learned what he's trying to do
basically take over the city and that
he's going to be using something from
Amazo Corp so we obviously got a tie to
the island now - we haven't met dr. Ivo
yet but he's actually going to be the
one behind the serum so look forward to
that in future episodes and we're also
going to meet the League of Assassins -
we haven't really learned too much about
them yet but that's gonna happen in the
next episode be sure to subscribe to get
that video I'll be posting that right
after next week's episode airs
I love the fight sequences with Oliver
in the Canary obviously she's much more
like arrow season 1 really vicious still
killing people so Oliver's gonna kind of
bring her back from the edge of insanity
but how fun was it watching them pick up
each other's signature weapons and just
using him like they had been doing it
their entire lives that just really
tells you that Sarah is going to be
Oliver's equal on the show this year I
also love that they revealed the true
identity of brother Bloods so soon
obviously I think a lot of people knew
that the brother blood character was
coming but we didn't really know what
the tie to Sebastian blood was if it was
just a brother or if it was actually him
himself but let me note your theories on
brother blood are and his relation to
the League of Assassins and Amazo Corp
and let me know what you think that
green serum is is it a Super Soldier
Serum like in the Marvel Universe
in other news don't forget I'm also
posting my next American Horror Story
coven video tomorrow morning if you
really want to help me out please like
and share this video while you wait for
that video you can click here to watch
my review of the x-men Days of Future
Passed trailer you
is amazing and you can click here to get
all my other videos from arrow season 2
thank you so much for watching happy
Halloween high-five see you guys
tomorrow
you